you obviously went through like a some
public disputes with some old Partners
uh that were coming out trying to sue
you um did you end up getting any of
that resolve what's the latest with that
n th those things take years and those
things are like mentally draining and
financially draining but like you know I
said it and I I could only talk very
little on it but like I I know 100% that
we're in the right and that when
everything comes to life people will be
like damn that boy went through all that
for what right and so I feel very
confident where we are no one's going to
come take cookies from me I am cookies
right no one's going to remove any of
the partners that helped me build this
along the way and I think that's part of
the unfortunate thing about building
something big is when you build
something big people will try to come
take that [__] but growing up I didn't
give up my lunch at school I'm not going
to start doing it now and I'm also not
going to jeopardize what we all Build
Together as as as a community because a
lot of people feel attached to cookies
and I mean a lot of people got tattoos
there's a there's a man in Tucson right
now with your portrait and the cookies
logo on his belly yeah no that's that's
real right that's a real human being I
saw my own eyes yeah and so the easy way
out would be just to bow down and take
something from them and just step but
like no dude people are fully invested
in this vision and this brand and what
we build together it's not just my [__]
it's our [__] all these operators around
the world they believed in what we built
to together right so I'm fighting for it
bro and I I feel like we're going to win
at the end of the day I feel like we're
going to come out on top it's just going
to take a lot of mental strength it's
going to take a lot of capital right
right that's why I stay grinding and
it's going to just take dedication and
loyalty from me and my partners and
that's it man how do you deal with um
coming out of getting through cancer and
then having to deal with just a whole
another hurdle obviously you got you
know stuff in your personal life going
on as well you know you you're you it
just you know you got to have some
mental fortitude to really get on the
other side of a battle with cancer well
the [__] up thing is that that lawsuit
started as soon as I got sick so that so
they were both happening at the same
time yeah I like when I found I was sick
it kind of conversations kind of
happened when I was need deep in chemo
and I was really really really sick this
ain't a sympathy card at all just like a
yo people could relate to what it feels
like being sick and thinking you're
going to die and also having threats of
your business being taken right almost
like it was on purpose hey man wild
timing on their end right right maybe
they didn't plan it that way but that's
the way it worked out and so it was kind
of tough but like it really put
everything in perspective for me I'm
like well first of all now I really got
to stick around right like I'm really
not going to have I can't go nowhere now
and it's really really made me realize
like the good precious moments like you
know with a peer things outside of
business and so you know for me that's
why that Cubs that Forbes cover felt
good coming out of that [__] it was like
a fan I'm being recognized I'm getting
my flowers while I'm here that's why the
ad age award the Cleo award these are
all big you know big [__] globally
recognized platforms that recognizing
what we're doing and so it just was the
motivation I need to keep fighting but
cancer was really really hard on me I
have major PTSD from that [__] and I'm
noticing more and more people getting
colon cancer at a young ass age and it's
just scary bro it's just like really
really and like a lot of men don't go
and get checked for that [__] no because
the symptoms are so I had zero symptoms
I had early stage tree colon cancer that
means another 6 months of letting that
ride it would have took my ass out so I
probably would have had a year or so if
I would have waited 6 months or more to
even get checked I probably would have
had a year or two years at most the
hardest thing for me to watch was like
the the brother you know shout out to
his whole family um his kids and his
wifey but you know seeing the inky boys
go through that we found out at the same
time m you know what I mean and I'm just
like damn bro like that [__] hurt and it
hit hard because I'm like damn not
everyone's going to have a chance to
make it through this and so I just take
a lot more calmer approach on life and
like stress and I just I feel blessed to
even be here bro and that's why I try to
tell people when people get stressed out
about money and things that's going on
but today's world I'm like bro like yeah
shit's tough with you're al man like you
can't you can't even downplay how big
that is right now for sure brother that
is I think that some people forget that
what was the um like what made you get
tested for for it was it just like a
normal run-of-the-mill doctor's visit no
because I was with the doctor already
that wouldn't even have ever looked for
that it was like some weird like
Universal gut feeling I I just had I
just woke up one day was looking down my
window I'm like damn I I actually got a
good life here things are going good I'm
successful I feel like cookies is going
to be something incredible that's going
to live forever like what am I actually
missing in life that where am I missing
at I'm
like maybe Health like I'm you know I'm
losing a little weight I'm not as big as
I used to be but maybe I should like get
myself a private doctor to really look
into what I got going on because you
know I just want to make sure I'm good
it's crazy cuz 5 years before this I had
a fear of having stomach cancer like my
mom I went got a colonoscopy 100% clean
wow 5 years so in 5 years window in 5
years that cancer developed and got to
early stage three and so I picked a
random ass um I picked a random ass day
that call my partner Parker and asked
him do we know any conci a doctors any
private doctors that could actually care
about me as a human or really looking at
me and we found a doctor that was not
only you know willing to take me on but
he's also investor into our business and
um he's the only doctor in the country
that did um does this test the gallery
test so when I went to go see him he was
like yo we can run you know all your
blood work and make sure you're good but
like this new test came out 2 months ago
I want to run it on you test for cancer
for 50 types of cancers through the
blood I'm like let's run it that's how
he found this [__] and an article came
out like maybe like 3 weeks ago I'm kind
of like one of the first people that
publicly took that test found that I had
cancer addressed it and made it through
the situation so there's a big debate
about this test right now not a lot of
doctors want to take it on because false
and positives that's the crazy [__] I've
ever heard in my life I saw it work for
me it saved me that's why I'm here right
now and I preach about this every time I
get a chance that that test should be
available it feels like an easy test to
take too like in terms of like when you
think like yeah it's a blood test blood
test and I would rather get a false
positive and think I'm going to have
cancer for a week and a half till they
go look inside my body and then find out
that I'm good right then like not know
anything at all yeah because you got
doctors that are doctors are I me man
you got good doctors you got doctors who
just getting a check it's like teachers
I look at doctors and teachers kind of
it's like anything in business doctor
being a doctor's business and you know
some of the institutions like even
though they're good doctors they just
don't have the bandwidth like if you're
at Kaiser Permanente you're seeing 4,000
patients right how could you actually
truly keep up with one of those patients
facts like even if you're a really good
person even if you don't have a hidden
agenda you're not getting attention yeah
you can't you're man withd is going to
be done you're not going to be able to
keep track of every and so you know for
all my people out there with money that
got money that care about their health
you know the new flex is getting coner
doctor get a doctor that's yeah all the
rap cats out there living fast on the
road not eating so well like yo [__]
that Gucci belt [__] that [__] that new
whip you know [__] [__] that new chain
[__] get yourself a coner doctor
and make sure you paying attention to
your health that's new flex really